what hello and welcome to this video
game Galbraith Galbraith so we looks
like you get a Queens gambit in yeah I
already do this yeah that's the Vienna
game where I don't have a good line I
mean I play this gambit because it's not
so much theory in comparison and then
blitz chess I think not knowing the
lines all that well is probably not as
important and you you kind of you get
them with with this beacon initiative
it's all such a big deal I feel is
sometimes maybe not get one hundred
percent enough but you it's easier to
play with the initiative so what I'm
trying to say not very successfully so
night wants to come to f5 I guess what
you six foot at five six most like
just fully developing here and see what
happens night at 5i probably dropped
back all the way to see one right now of
hanging threaten turn the night through
the night capture was threatened so c5
wow it looks completely wrong to the
others opening up everything yeah that's
the way to do it are you sure I take it
and 27 probably and there are there are
some tactics are like night to have
seven that they don't work yet very
close though the hive is also move that
it looks interesting they're all kinds
of discoveries them
and I don't don't see him I don't see it
direct after takes Bishop takes Knight
is comely I don't see working I've got
visual f7 as in as a threat first so
[Music]
okay when yes he has to take on d5 right
is there anything else even Luke takes
is kind of interesting please doing it
with a temple night except seven and
then Luke takes a five something that is
on the card shakes maybe 936 and
pauletta that's not my kind of position
as pure calculation and it's fairly
obvious that it should be good for white
but I mean i'ma fall down on b2 which is
unimportant and I've got everything
developed and he's got nothing out
Bishop 1c8 look on a eight the king is
in the diagonal so it was pretty clear
that there should be something good for
Wyatt but finding it is there not is a
different matter okay anyway if you move
the Queen then I can take on f7 I mean
my book takes root great mate so this
was this is a key idea here I was just
not sure if there's something else
something freaky and let head that I
don't see correctly 93 days Bishop takes
f7 that's going to going to be
devastating
we should have 17 h eight and queen h5
for example threatening 96 mate so
that's it winning for what yeah this
isn't this almost same thing so okay I
can also throw if you can take with the
night but aunty a text my bishop Wow yet
is what I meant with not my kind of
position move like that irritate me to
no end okay if i move the Queen like to
eat 50 65 the should f7 look at seven
light at seven we should take street 49
takes 28 we should take the one that
cannot even count that it's okay for him
material wise amazingly Queenie for this
bishop at five miracle move but it is
there don't tell me is like holding from
black and would be absolute joke here
really ninety form can I do just and
then queen age five I have to play now I
mean time wise it's a disaster anyway so
Luke takes I'm thinking queen age five
but then g6 does the trick again night
at seven Bishop g4 98 is good for black
Jesus this is the kind of game I hate to
do small stay when you know that there's
a win I just don't see it I'm just too
bad in calculation to to just see the
wind I mean if there wasn't that that
would be extremely strange
maybe it would be five here instead of
Bishop d5 and I know maybe I'm still
okay yeah and the knight on d4 hangs we
should take group takes and Bishop takes
Queen takes should win the night back
never cook you should be for all kinds
of stuff g6 I have to take on g6 to the
night which is probably not or then
maybe night of 7 now that could work in
yeah then I can take on f7 actually
after g6 this is basically moving out of
the attack so maybe I am ok so Bishop
takes is five Luke chicks look chicks is
possible it's not completely bonkers
Queen takes bishop g voice is annoying
really that's probably what's going to
happen or something else entirely that
would be shocking and probably get to a
time loss it yeah okay Bishop g4 the
ambition of three is the thing that
doesn't work every Bishop a three I mean
no no I'm ahead on the clock [ __ ]
probably winning this on time or move 20
years oh and getting it back I think so
once this cover town actual is covered
black 4x I'm trying so windows on time
and it was a crit was crazy I mean if
I'm not a winning in this position and
it would be crazy I hate is it is crazy
this game is crazy sometimes so black
has no development no development here
and play c5 in the face of this why is
that possible I was thinking I would
have to defend with some slowish movie I
like Spain it's here never know Bishop
d7 or whatever and c5 is not losing I
mean what that's really strange the
engine doesn't find anything special I
am that's amazing
I'm stunned okay so g5 takes yeah Luke
teeth or something I considered but I
couldn't quite fit back the n96 was one
move but I also couldn't quite figure
out what i would do after this computer
gives Creed you won or something equal
yeah ok so in 94 that that probably was
the rule here many moves didn't work I
mean something like this I can take on
f7 I shot right in that can be answered
with 93 and then I would have never
never found any of this here this and
then cream three four okay and equal
material great this distant work and I
will check should have seven and now
Queen h5 and let that I had seen at
least and this I didn't even see okay
yeah and that doesn't seem to work fully
now yeah 24 is the engines move and then
Bishop f5 this is basically where
stopped but ok this SEO puzzled King h8
and 3d fiber that's very unhuman check
eng basically lost the game by spending
90 90 seconds and this was good though
now look at six now I had the tricky
move here for loop 36
yeah it's good times this is a good move
the engine gives f3 with a very big
advantage hope like a 3g 16g 320 until
yeah geez I'm I'm okay here one more
time I am so completely part completely
dumbfounded that c5 is a trailer movie
in this position I mean even consider
that remotely with black because it
looks completely crazy there is working
i mean it's looking to should a 3m
that's not not a bad idea probably I am
so stunned anyway thanks for watching